[Musik]
mit einer fernsehansprache wendet sich
der russische präsident putin an sein
volk und ordnet die teilmobilmachung der
streitkräfte an die noch heute beginnen
soll 300.000 reservisten mit
kampferfahrung so hofft der kreml
könnten damit an die front geschickt
werden eine weitere eskalation nach
sieben monaten krieg in der ukraine
herzlich willkommen zu einem zdf spezial
die nachfolgenden sendungen verschieben
sich um circa zehn minuten
als zeichen der schwäche als
verzweiflungstat bezeichnet viele detail
mobilisierung in russland gleichzeitig
ist die sorge groß vor einer ausweitung
des krieges der drastische schritt kommt
zu einem zeitpunkt im krieg an dem die
ukraine auf dem vormarsch ist wichtige
geländegewinne erzielt hat über die lage
an der front martin hanika
sie sollen verstärkung bekommen die
russischen soldaten an der front heute
vom russischen verteidigungsministerium
veröffentlichtes material soll sie
zeigen irgendwo in der ukraine
das für russlands ami längst nicht alles
nach plan verläuft kann selbst die
russische propaganda nicht verdecken zu
groß sind die gebiete die die ukraine
seit kriegsbeginn wieder zurückerobert
hat hier grau dargestellt
zuletzt etwa in der region kharkiv bis
zur grenze im norden und bis zum schluss
aus kiel im osten haben sie die
russischen truppen vertrieben
sie setzten die stabilisierungsmaßnahmen
in denen von russischer besatzung
befreiten gebieten fort die situation an
der front zeigt klar dass wir das heft
des handelns in der hand haben unsere
verteidiger erfüllen sehr sorgfältig und
sehr tapfer die vorgaben ihrer
kommandeure
die man direkt an der front noch ist die
kleinstadt in russischer hand an der
seite von prorussischen separatisten
konnte das französische fernsehen mit
menschen in der stadt sprechen die
meisten sind längst geflohen
wir haben angst aber wir brauchen essen
nur deshalb sind wir hier
das ist immer so
noch nicht nur direkt an der front auch
im hinterland treffen die ukraine ziele
die hier in noida
und auch in der großstadt netz ist
gefechtslärm zu hören
die ukrainische offensive kann
allerdings nicht verhindern dass
russland weiterhin ziele auf
ukrainischem gebiet angreift in kharkiv
hat es heute nacht wieder
raketenangriffe gegeben getroffen hat es
unter anderem ein wohnhaus
die explosion war so stark die wände
sind sofort zusammengebrochen weil meine
fenster wurden herausgerissen alle vier
und so tobt der krieg in der ukraine
weiter detail mobilisierung in russland
wird ihn vermutlich noch verlängern
und in berlin spreche ich jetzt mit der
deutschen verteidigungsministerium
christine lambrecht guten abend
guten abend frau lambrecht was bedeutet
die russische teil mobilmachung für den
krieg in der ukraine
diese mobilmachung offenbart die
schwäche russlands ist zeigt dass der
plan dieses furchtbaren dieses grausamen
angriffskrieges nicht aufgeht auch
sympathisch schwäche sowohl militärisch
als auch politisch und wie sehr wächst
damit die gefahr dass deutschland mit in
den krieg hineingezogen wird
deutschland wird auch in zukunft ganz
konsequent an der seite der ukraine
stehen sehr konsequent aber auch sehr
besonnen das ist uns ganz wichtig darauf
kann sich die ukraine verlassen aber
wächst die gefahr mit hineingezogen zu
werden noch mehr
wir haben immer deutlich gemacht dass
wir die ukraine unterstützen in ihrem
kampf gegen
diesen furchtbaren angriffs trägt das
wir unterstützen mit geld aber eben auch
mit waffen das ist ein ganz klares
signal aber wir werden immer darauf
achten dass wir nicht kriegspartei
werden und das werden wir auch in
zukunft so handhaben ja aber braucht die
ukraine nicht gerade jetzt deutsche
waffen auch kampfpanzer um das momentum
auszunutzen wenn die teilmobilmachung
wirklich wie der bundeskanzler ja auch
sagt eine verzweiflungstat ist
die ukraine wird jetzt sehr schnell
panzer geliefert bekommen nämlich 40
panzer aus griechenland 28 aus slowenien
und deutschland wird helfen diese lücken
in den beiden ländern dann zu schließen
und darüber hinaus werden wir die
ukraine auch mit deutschen waffen
systemen mit sehr effektiven
waffensystemen unterstützen
beispielsweise mit weiteren
panzerhaubitzen mit mehrfach
raketenwerfern mit luftverteidigung mit
gepanzerten fahrzeugen
selbstverständlich werden wir die
ukraine weiter unterstützen jetzt mehr
denn je aber weiter nicht mit leopard 2
es ist ganz wichtig dass die ukraine
jetzt waffen bekommt mit denen auch
sofort bekämpft werden kann und mit den
panzern aus griechenland mit den panzern
aus lohr ringe mit unseren
panzerhaubitzen mit dem mehrfacher
kinder werfen ist das möglich weil es
eben keine weitere ausbildung mehr
braucht die panzer aus griechenland und
slowenien kennen die ukraine und an
unseren systemen wurde bereits
ausgebildet in dem von russland
besetzten teile im osten des landes
seien am freitag schein abstimmungen
über eine zugehörigkeit zu russland
abgehalten werden heißt dass angriffe
auf diese gebiete wären dann angriffe
auf russland mit der gefahr eines atom
schlags als gegenreaktion oder ist das
nur eine drohgebärde um den westen zu
verunsichern
diese gebiete sind ukrainisches
territorium und das bleiben sie und da
spielen auch referenten die jetzt
abgehalten werden keine rolle zumindest
nicht für uns für uns ist ganz klar das
ist ukrainisches territorium
aber wir müssen natürlich immer im blick
haben auch welche reaktionen putin
welche reaktionen aus russland erfolgen
und selbstverständlich beobachten wir
auch die frage ob drohungen wahr gemacht
werden aber in den kopf von putin in
seiner strategie reinzuschauen ist
schwieriger denn je aber davon lassen
wir uns nicht abschrecken pfiffikus
halten sie denn die gefahr eines
nuklearen anschlags
ich habe den eindruck dass hier sehr
viel gedroht wird dass versucht wird
einzuschüchtern das auch versucht wird
die allianz die unterstützung der
ukraine auseinanderzudividieren das wird
aber auch durch solche drohungen nicht
das muss ein ganz klares signal in
richtung russland sein wir werden weiter
an der seite der ukraine stehen vielen
dank vollem recht
das gespräch haben wir vor der sendung
aufgezeichnet
und wie reagiert die ukraine dort heißt
es die teilmobilmachung seine große
tragödie für die russen und zeigen nur
die unfähigkeit seiner truppen
gleichzeitig die große sorge noch mehr
soldaten heißt auch noch mehr kämpfe
noch mehr tote aus mikolaj torge bode
viktor zeigt uns sein schlafzimmer sein
haus liegt genau gegenüber der
universität von nikolov die wurde am 16
august von einer russischen rakete
getroffen
hier habe ich geschlafen nach dem ersten
angriff wenn nicht schnell aufgestanden
und ich habe es noch in den bunker
geschafft
72 jahre hat viktor hier gewohnt seit
seiner geburt die druckwelle der rakete
reist das dach weg auch im haus geht
einiges zu bruch er glaubt dass durch
die teilmobilmachung am ende auch
ukraine gegen ukraine aufgehetzt werden
ich bin mir sicher dass bei dieser
mobilmachung unsere eigenen leute in den
besetzten gebieten gezwungen werden zu
kämpfen und dann kämpft ein volk
gegeneinander
nikolajew eine hafenstadt am schwarzen
meer die südliche frontlinie ist nur
rund 15 kilometer entfernt noch immer
gibt es hier fast täglich luftalarm
[Musik]
noch mehr russische soldaten an der
front das bedeutet nichts gutes fürchten
viele
natürlich habe ich angst das bedeutet
dass noch mehr geschossen wird die
schießen immer weiter jede nacht und
niemand kann sie aufhalten
wir hoffen auf unsere soldaten auf
unserer armee die unterstützung der
menschen ich glaube am ende wird alles
gut wir hoffen darauf
das bedeutet dass mehr menschen sterben
werden junge männer werden zum krieg
eingezogen es wird mehr verluste geben
ganz einfach
auf einem truppenübungsplatz trainiert
kommandant markus junge soldaten am
gewehr die neuen nachrichten aus moskau
nimmt er gelassen entgegen dass der
kampferprobte soldaten an die front
geschickt werden glaubt er nicht
solche nachrichten von der teil machen
ändert gar nichts wir müssen sowieso
unser land befreien das sind nur
provokationen des aggressors
die menschen in den besetzten gebieten
verstehen dass durch die mobilisierung
am ende einfache menschen zum
kanonenfutter werden könnten viktor hat
gerade ganz handfeste sorgen er hofft
dass sein dach vor dem winter repariert
werden kann dass der krieg bis dahin
vorbei ist glaubt er nicht
über die teilmobilmachung heute sprechen
wir jetzt mit der russland und osteuropa
expertin lerner fix in berlin im namen
warum dieser schritt heute und was
bedeutet er konkret
ja dieser schritt heute war eine
reaktion des russischen präsidenten auf
die verluste auf die ukrainischen
erfolge es ist ein eingeständnis dass
wenn dieser schritt nicht gegangen
worden wäre russland möglicherweise den
krieg in der ukraine verloren hätte es
ist ein versuch die ukraine davon
abzuschrecken weitere offensiven zu
führen und im westen von weiterer
unterstützung abzuschrecken und dazu
dienen auch die scheine referenten mit
denen eine basis geschaffen werden soll
um die mobi die mobilisierung der
russischen armee auf russisches
territorium auf angeblich russisches
territorium auszureiten es ist
allerdings ein sehr riskanter schritt
weil zum ersten mal dieser krieg jetzt
wirklich auch bei der russischen
bevölkerung selbst ankommt und nicht
mehr nur eine spezialoperation ist sie
sagen welche folgen wird das in russland
selbst haben bisher bayer immer nur von
einer spezialoperation der rede die man
offiziell unter kontrolle hatte
ja tatsächlich ist das für die russische
bevölkerung ein neues kapitel dieses
krieges und es bedeutet dass der krieg
in den wohnzimmern in russland
angekommen ist bisher hat war der krieg
populär allerdings gab es keine
bereitschaft selbst in diesem krieg zu
kämpfen der krieg ist sozusagen
außerhalb der eigenen lebensrealität für
die meisten russinnen und russen
insbesondere in den metropolen moskau
und sankt petersburg geblieben und die
tatsache dass wir eine teil
mobilisierung sehen zeigt dass sich
putin des risikos es in politischen
risikos in dem er sich befindet bewusst
ist er versucht damit diejenigen zu
beruhigen die bisher noch nichts mit dem
militär zu tun hatten in dem er gesagt
hat in seiner rede dass nur diejenigen
mit militärischer erfahrung in betracht
kommen real stellt sich aber natürlich
jetzt jede familie in russland die frage
wenn dieser schritt jetzt gegangen wird
was ist der nächste schritt und wen kann
es als nächstes nächsten treffen wenn
wie in dem dekret vom russischen
präsidenten steht auch in gewissen
regionen quoten erfüllt werden müssen
von rekrutierten männern
der russische opposition ruft zu
protesten auf wie gefährlich könnte das
verbreitung putin werden
ja seine legitimation ist eng mit dem
ausgang dieses krieges verbunden und
dieser schritt bindet ihn noch enger
sein eigenes schicksal und das schicksal
seiner seines regimes noch enger an den
ausgang des krieges tatsächlich haben
wir in einigen städten in russland
proteste in zweistelliger zahl gesehen
insgesamt wird von 200 verhafteten
aktivisten und aktivisten gesprochen wir
sehen also keine massenproteste im
moment allerdings muss man auch sagen
zumindest im moment allerdings muss man
auch sagen und die stadt moskau hat
davon nochmals gewarnt dass proteste
auch mit großem risiko verbunden sind
und möglicherweise zu freiheitsstrafen
von bis zu 15 jahren führen können es
ist also keine leichte situation für
diejenigen die sich gegen diese
mobilisierung in russland wehren wollen
viele wählen stattdessen den weg
russland zu verlassen über die letzten
freien visafreien routen nach armenien
georgien oder in andere länder die kein
visum benötigen
vielen dank für die einschätzung nach
berlin werner fix
dass unser zdf spezial zur neuesten
eskalation im krieg gegen die ukraine
mehr informationen später im
heute-journal und natürlich jederzeit in
unserer zdf heute app einen schönen
abend noch auf wiedersehen
[Musik]